my talk is called everything i've
learned i have learned from somebody
else uh this talk could also have been
called
the technology of yesterday or tomorrow
i mean today
right so i feel a little bit
out of place having to follow up
professor sussman and um joe armstrong i
mean these are like uh you know
really big people i'm just a guy who
does javascript the new york times
um so i'll try my best
to say something interesting to this
fantastic group of of people
exploring new approaches to
engineering solutions to the type of
software problems we have today
so on the flight here i was reading this
book
called the dream machine which was
recommended recently on alan kaye's
mailing list which i like to lurk on
it's by waldrop and it documents the
history around lick lighter who was
pivotal in the in arpa he ran arpa
and this is why we have the internet and
to a large degree why there was a lot of
research funding put into the creation
of programming languages and
new kinds of computing technology and we
are reaping the benefits of that today
but when you read this you know these
they talk about wine uh sorry weiner
they talk about
uh von neumann shannon um they talk
about you know k's in there
um i mean everybody and it's like really
exciting like they're right there
you know and this is the 30s and the 40s
i mean
nobody would have believed that i would
be sitting here up on the stage in 2013
with essentially a supercomputer
right so this is pretty amazing um yet
yet now we have a culture which is very
much around engineering
and and i think it's really exciting to
see that we have got to this point where
we're sort of sick of the status quo
and there's a resurgence and not a
resurgence from the academic community
but a resurgence among engineers and
excitement around
uh new programming language and i think
this is pretty cool
so my own story starts uh which probably
for many of you it also started here i
started programming on an absolute gs
using basic
and so but something kind of stuck with
me when i did this um which was
it was there was a nice feedback loop it
was very fast you type some commands you
can modify your program on the fly
it was very i mean it was basic but
there's something about that which i
think is why i
i i personally tend to use um lisp like
systems
but this is also why i'm mostly
interested in interactive applications
and ui so my perspective is often
not from like can i build this
concurrent server technology or can i
build a distributed system
but how can we craft um compelling
uh interactive experiences uh for
clients
uh and there's a funny quote by by
dijkstra which says
having used basic i'm now mentally
mutilated beyond all regeneration
so you might have to take anything i say
with a grain of salt um
but we'll see i'll try to redeem myself
um
so yeah this is the quote
okay so uh five years ago i was i've
been doing javascript for a long
time eight years doing ui stuff but five
years ago i started playing around this
language called closure
and my interest in it was again not from
like really caring about functional
programming or all this stuff it was
oh it runs in the jvm and i can interact
with a rebel on the fly
with the processing environment which is
a sort of creative coding environment
that's really popular
some of may some of you may have heard
processing js was a javascript version
of it
but that was actually my initial
interest was like oh i can actually
develop these applications on the fly
without having to go through this
tedious
compile fix my bugs compile cycle
but so the deeper i got into closure i
was like oh this is very interesting so
i was coming from
a lot of experience in java and c c plus
plus um javascript of course
objective c um and it was very different
once i started digging into closure i
was like oh this is kind of interesting
closure takes these sort of
academic ideas right it's sort of a dot
it takes them and modifies them and
tries to make them more practical
right so okazaki talked about purely
functional data structures
is very well known uh in the um
definitely in the haskell community and
oh camel and definitely enclosure
but the thing is that closure actually
isn't about the type of
of purely functional data structures
that okazaki described right
closures data structures are are much
more about bagwell style data structures
which can be mutable or they can be
immutable and what's cool about
bagwell's data structures
is that they're have very good
complexity characteristics
in fact so good that they're that
they're either basically drop in
replacements
for the type of collection mutable
collections that most programmers and
mainstream languages
use and so this was kind of like an eye
opener wow you took
academic research which was basically
proved you could
provide a you know a real solution um
that can be a drop in replacement for
mutable stuff right the cost is not too
high
um and so closure i think did a lot to
make uh what might have seemed like an
esoteric
piece of technology into something
practical so uh this sort of got me
excited and i started like well maybe i
should start reading papers again like i
hadn't really looked at any
serious computer science since i'd read
sick pee like uh
quite some time ago so um
and uh i thoroughly recommend looking at
um the
bagwell and romf did a a new version is
called rrb trees which actually
describes
um the bitmap vector tri which is
actually an invention by rich hickey
he took the hash array map try idea and
specialize it to
a data structure that works more like an
array and it's and it's actually
i think the best introduction to how
clever you can get
with the hash array map try concept
so um i i read it so i was like getting
more excited i was like oh this is cool
all this pain all these papers there's
lots of interesting things and maybe
maybe there's stuff to find that people
haven't looked at maybe there are
other ideas like this that we can
implement um that can solve
problems so i encountered the reason
schemer because this guy jim dewey had
ported this thing called mini cameron
which i didn't know about
and i found out it was described in this
book by dan and will who are
in attendance and oleg kislyak who's
very well known in the haskell community
and so basically what they showed by
taking actually quite a few prior papers
one in haskell they converted into
scheme and said we can build something
like prologue
in about 200 lines of scheme and this
was like shocking to me
that you could do this and not only do
this but it could be reasonably
performant
so i really wanted to understand how
this worked the other thing was that
on oleg site the reason i got excited
about this was on oleg site he has a 300
line
mini cameron program that shows you how
to do henley milner
type inference type checking and type
inhabitation
in 300 lines right so you're like oh i
can understand that but if i understand
this system
i want to know about that so i i looked
up um
will's dissertation will's dissertation
came out four years after the
publication of the reason schemer and
this was the first time that
there was anything resembling
documentation about what the
what the implementation how it actually
worked
[Laughter]
and so i i got really excited about it
because finally there was there was some
way for me to understand how how that's
what that scheming code was trying to do
and it was great it was a great read
um i ended up sending uh will and dan a
big thank you thank you for documenting
this and
they ended up coming to the very first
or the second closure conference because
i built an implementation of mini
cameron for closure which is called
corelogic
so it wasn't just about taking their
ideas
um they they actually are they're always
playing they're always they're always
doing different versions of mini cameron
um but i was very curious about you know
being somebody who works on interactive
applications
can this system be made faster can it be
made more efficient you know
often when you're doing something
interactive you're like can i get a
better frame rate you know can i can i
can i reduce latency in some part of my
program so i was very curious
what are like how far can i push this
you know sort of taking an
engineer's eye on what may seem like an
academic idea
so i read this paper called the
efficient representation efficient
representations for triangular
substitutions
where they actually try different
representations in the original program
they used a linked list
which works fine but they started
documenting what are the performance
characteristics of other data structures
and so the substitution i'm not going to
get into it but it's basically like a
place to store variables and what
they're bound to
and i said well this sounds like a it
sounds like a hash map
why don't we just stick a persistent
hash map in there how fast is that going
to be
and in fact i did that and it was
basically as fast as the
fastest representation that they come up
with in this paper which is also like
very much a map a hash map like data
structure
so the other thing that happened was
that if you know
spew speed back daniel speedwack talked
about this in in earlier
which is that there's a very much an
old-school style fp
which is sort of characterized probably
which which is fine scheme is great but
it's sort of characterized by scheme
and that you have lots of conditional
statements and sort of the promise and
the thing that people always liked about
objects was that
you could have this sort of polymorphism
and allen k critiqued
uh prologue because prologue has a baked
in
unchangeable notion of equality right
you can't fix
unification unification is set once and
for all for prologue and allen k said
wow such a great idea prologue but you
can't you can't change what equality
means in prologue this is a serious flaw
in the design of that system and this is
documented in this
paper by cornfield which i recommend
reading a quality for prologue
a version of prologue that has equality
but this is a known problem in the
functional programming computing
community right um that you really want
a quality be something that can be
overloaded
object-oriented programmers and
functional programmers know this
wadler talks about it in 1988 right how
to make ad hoc polymorphism
less ad hoc right that standard ml had a
hack
standard ml had a hack for the for the
quality right
and then water says this is this is
ridiculous we should formalize this
concept
right people are going to want to do
this and in order to make our programs
more expressive
we need something like type classes so
this is the paper where they
where they talk we're introduced type
classes so closure has had uh had
recently gotten protocols
and so sorry i recently got a protocol
and so i said what i want is type class
eq
for logic programming so when i when i
when i took uh
when i built corelogic i said i want
unification to be polymorphic
and openly extendable so that if you
have some other data structure that we
don't
we haven't thought of ahead of time you
can make it participate in unification
and it and it works and it's great and
people and the people that have used it
really like it
in fact nada amin who is also here who
uh did a programming uh pro uh
program transformations workshop which i
think was probably totally awesome that
i didn't get to see
because i was working on this um she
actually said oh i want to implement
this thing called nominal logic
programming which is also in will's
thesis they had done a variant of mini
camera that lets you do um sort of these
theoretical computer science stuff on
the lambda calculus but allow it's nice
because it lets you talk about binding
uh the binding the meaning of binding in
in lambda terms
and so she was able to leverage the fact
that we have
polymorphic unification right that
unification isn't baked in
we could define a new type of term
called nominal and we can say what
unification means
and so integration with her work was
trivial right it was just like oh yeah
you you have that it's that extension
point it's just there
um and i think there this is this is
again taking some idea and saying well
how can we make this
uh more work in a more broad way in a
more generic way
but again taking these really fantastic
ideas and maybe adding a little bit of
engineering principles to them so the
other thing that i did was uh i think a
lot of people are
are sadly unaware of of prologue
prologue is still fairly active in
the european community but it's more or
less dead on this side of the ocean
but i thoroughly recommend reading this
book concepts techniques and models
computer programming they talk about a
lot of things but the part that i was
fascinated by
was constraint logic programming um
because it takes the
the beautiful notion of prolog and it
takes it a step further because prologue
strategy
doesn't really work for all types of
problems that you might want to describe
and constraint logic programming sort of
opens the door in fact it was in the 80s
where
the original ventures of prologue came
up with this thing called prologue 3
which had constraints so and this this
this work is still ongoing
it's also very related to sussman and
rodule's work the art of the propagator
which is also a fantastic paper
they talk about a lot of things but also
here they sort of describe this
really incredible notion of constraints
right being able to succinctly describe
constraints and because of that you have
some sort of model that you set up you
can run the constraints and it will
produce answers
in a very efficient manner um
so we did this i wanted this this is yet
another thing that i was like i got i
have to have that and so claire and will
and dan they worked on claire alves they
worked on this thing called c
cameron where they were they taught
described how you could do this in
scheme and once again i read the paper
great paper
i said well i want more data structures
i can see
that with a fixed point algorithm slower
and i want to fix that and
and so on and then at the end you know
after a bunch of work we now have
this in corelogic and so a lot of this
is not just
like use this but exposing people
to the idea to the concept to think that
this might be a way you want to solve
problems
in fact corelogic is slower than two of
the best constraint solvers that are out
there that have been worked on for more
than a decade
one is called uh one is in c plus plus
called g code
which can solve finite domain problems
very quickly i mean ten to probably a
thousand times faster than core logic
another one is called jakop for the jvm
which also can solve
uh finite domain problems um ten to a
hundred times faster than corelogic and
this is stuff that i
ask people if we'll have you still
they'll state some problem i'll be like
gosh that sounds like a finite domain
problem
and then you write see them write a
bunch of code i'm like well you know
there's solvers for this stuff right
and really fast solvers they've been
worked on continuously
for 10 years um okay so that's the first
part
now i'm going to sort of switch gears so
that was my um
like why i like logic programming and
how i think it might be useful
um and this is the other part so though
i did object oriented programming for a
very long time
and one of the coolest things about
closure when i encountered it was that
it was functional programming
but it didn't completely abandon um the
sort of sort of object-oriented thinking
and this existed in the early days
enclosure as multi-methods
right and so multi-methods were sort of
like an object-oriented thing though
they were more expressive
i thought they were quite cool but the
thing again as
spiwak said earlier in his talk um they
sort of live on this weird part of the
performance spectrum we have protocols
which are very fast
because they're backed by java
interfaces and we have multi methods
which are really expressive
but they're really slow and so i was
very interested in
uh efficient predicate dispatch which
was supposed to sort of unify
what people like about pattern matching
what people like about multiple dispatch
but without the sort of performance the
poor performance you see
with multi methods and so i looked at
this paper um
because it was recommended by richiki
and there i saw a little diagram which
shows the decision tree
how you can build a very efficient
decision tree for doing efficient
predicate dispatch
and i said man that looks like some
stuff i've seen in the ml community the
ml community has been working on
uh making pattern matching faster since
1984. i think there was like i think
that might have been the first like how
to how to make efficient
how to do efficient pattern matching in
a functional programming language um
but i encountered this recent paper this
is from 2008 called compiling pattern
matching to good decision trees by
luke moran j and this is about oh camel
and he had this amazing graphic which
looks extremely similar
right to the the the dag that we saw for
efficient predicate dispatch i was like
wait there absolutely is a connection
here like the same strategies are being
used
for two different systems one for object
orientation and one for functional
programming
um so in this paper luke moran j
describes how if you adopt a lazy
pattern matching semantics
where here you see this is the path to
one particular leaf node
one particular action that's describing
the pattern and notice that there are
many tests that need to be made
and there are many possible ways to the
same leaf right the same action
the same matching liner if you will
if you apply lazy pattern matching
semantics if you
you choose the right columns test first
you can get a much more
optimal decision tree so here you see
there's only one path
to the leaf and there's only four tests
so less
tests and one path right so this means
less code to generate as well
so i said that looks really amazing i
want to understand how this works let's
implement this enclosure because closure
doesn't even have pattern matching but
we have macros right so we can we can
actually trivially implement the
algorithm present in the paper
so here's some o'camel code you don't
have to know camel if you know erlang or
ml or haskell this should be pretty
obvious there's a function then a local
function that takes
three parameters which are booleans and
then we have a set of clauses about
matching over those
those values so if we naively
compile this we're going to get a camel
code that looks like this the equivalent
equivalent match might look something
like this notice that we have we have
three
three opportunities to match three it
appears three times the
third clause also note that we test x
first
even though on the first line x is a
wild card
it doesn't matter right so this is the
naive
decision tree so i want to explain the
decision tree process because it's
actually a very neat idea and
it might have applicability to other
problems
so here's what it looks like in core
match which is at the pattern matching
library
i implemented using um luke maranje's
ideas
this is the same sort of expression so
what do we do
we take the pattern matrix right and we
and we we set it up so we have the
variables at the top
we have the actions on the right on the
on the right and then we have the
sort of matrix of of of patterns
exactly like it appeared in the source
code it's exactly the same
um so what we notice is that we have
wild cards and we have what are called
constructors these these actual things
that we want to match
right so what luke says is that what if
we give wild what do we score the
columns
anywhere there's a wild card we get we
put a zero so so where we see a wild
card is zero
whenever we see a constructor we give a
value like one
and anything that's beneath the
constructor so in under z you notice you
have
the v you have f and t under a wild card
those don't get to contribute to a
column score
so obviously here from just doing this
very simple analysis
we know that we have to test y first we
can skip testing x
and then what we do is we move we move y
to the front
the y column is now in the front and now
we can make a decision
either y is going to be false or it's
going to be
one of the four other remaining cases so
let's move forward in the compilation
process and say we say okay y is false
we're no longer considering y and we are
now left with just that
top row and we have x and z to consider
well x is a wild card we only test z
right and then when we are done with
testing z
we only have wild cards things we do not
need to look at
we never need to look at them um
so with the op by applying his algorithm
we now have something that looks exactly
like what i described
we we look at why first only then do we
consider
x and you see there are many cases if we
look at y and we look at z for example
if
y is false then we only have to consider
z and we know
so this is the optimal decision tree
there's less less cases to consider less
tests to do
so this is done that's actually been
implemented in closure the only
languages that actually do this that i'm
aware of is racket and
enclosure but we can go further so
wadler talked about in 1987
this was 27 years ago wilder said
the whole ml haskell o'camel habit of
pattern matching on concrete data types
is a horrible idea
and you guys are still doing this today
right you're you're matching concrete
types
not abstractions and water says we have
to stop doing this
right if we're going to write generic
code you have to
you have to match on abstractions and so
i said we already do that enclosure
enclosure we don't care what the
concrete type is we have we have types
that represent
the same conceptual thing there are many
implementations for example
of things that are map-like i never care
as a clojure programmer
what type of map-like thing i have right
and this is really important
we have we write very reusable code so i
thought to myself
how how much how difficult would it be
to make um
[ __ ] jay's algorithm work for hash maps
right and this this actually you could
do this but not just do it for hash maps
but
optimize it for hash maps so
take here we have a hash map and say
it's x and so what what the user is
saying here is that i want to match a
map
that at least has the key a i don't care
what it is
and then it has to have b and it has to
be equal to two and then the second
match as well a has to be one and b
equals one where it gets curious is the
last line the last line is a map which
doesn't refer to any of the keys in the
first two
right so we put this into a matrix
like this and then all we have to do the
thing is that we have to the
if we're going to analyze the contents
of the maps we have to make sure that
the next step that we look at
we have the same number of rows and
columns right they have to be the same
so the only only thing we have to do is
we just assume
that those are wild card tests right
so even though the even though that
first pattern doesn't have a c a d
or an e we don't care those are wild
cards the algorithm says we never have
to look at them
anyway right the only other trick then
we have to play is that
we need a new pattern type which is this
existence pattern
which and we have to change our scoring
so now constructors like concrete values
we score them a bit higher um these
existence tests
score a little bit lower and then wild
cards are still zero
and then obviously we can test we need
to test b
first so closure has this we optimize
pattern matching
on hash maps in the same way that the
algorithm can can optimize
concrete types
but we can go yet a step further so this
is anything i was like just exploring
pattern matching and so i was like okay
we can do
luke brandy's algorithm we can do um we
can do
views something like views but we can
also do extensible pattern matching so
sam tobin hodgstad who worked on the
matcher for racket
said there's no reason in a lisp to
close the language right so in a lot of
functional programming languages that
ship with pattern matching the language
is closed
you as the user of that pattern matching
system cannot customize it to your needs
so there's no reason to do this in a
list so
taking a page out of the book of this
book which allen k was said was the
most important book on objective
programming in 10 years in
upsla 97
cozales wrote another paper which is
really fascinating called
compilation strategies objects which is
a pretty crazy idea
that that you could actually have a
compilation process and it's an object
and you can derive it right you could
take somebody else's compilation process
derive it extend it and have a new one
so we did this
in in core match right so we have vector
pattern matching in core match
where you're allowed to match closure
vectors but the thing is it's completely
abstract
right all that it matters that you have
to have a have a
random access data type there are other
random access data types that we care
about
java arrays um and binary data right
those they're the random access in
exactly the same way vectors are
so here i can derive using multi methods
i can divide derive the compilation
procedure for vectors and specialize
them to arrays
and all i need to do is let the users
give me the inlining
what statements must be inline to make
that work so
describe how we can access a random
random access into an array
that's a get enclosure how do we how do
we count
the number of elements in array that's
count or sorry a length enclosure
and then how can we talk about a
subsection of the array and of course
we're not going to actually do a
subsection it's just like a virtual
subsection
how do we define that and then at the
very bottom we can specialize that again
for um java arrays of objects and this
will give us
more or less an order of magnitude uh
increase in speed
over red black trees as per system
vectors so if you encode your red black
trees
as java arrays you can match an order of
magnitude faster on them
so this you can run this expression um
10 million iterations in one second
if your encoding is um uh as object
arrays
okay so that's that's dispatching that's
pretty cool lots of interesting ideas
ideas around dispatching
and hopefully we can use some of those
stuff for for doing predica dispatch
which is sort of an object oriented idea
so i want to end with the last thing
because this is a fairly new thing in
the closure community but it's extremely
relevant um
if you're doing ui stuff i think and
this is uh tony horse communicating
sequential processes which is a really
old also a very old idea
um it's been recently popularized by go
uh an imperative language that's taking
taking hold um i don't really care for
it but doesn't matter
it has has chan has a csp abstraction
and that part of the language
is quite interesting and it's quite cool
um
the thing is that that people have tried
this before and they've actually been
quite successful
with it but it's been in languages that
people weren't using
um so uh standard ml had
um a variant of it called concurrent ml
which had csp
in the language and they actually built
a user interface toolkit
using csp it was called excine right
and so this actually now exists today uh
because
core async which just got released works
in closure
and in closure script so we can use the
exactly the same techniques
and the same research that was done in
their toolkit system
so this now gives what i think a much
better story
in a functional programming language for
doing serious ui work
um and the thing the beautiful thing
about csp is that it actually combines
very cleanly with
all the current excitement around
functional reactive programming right
it's not like csp and
all this cool stuff that people during
the function reactive programming is
separate we can actually
put them together and reap the benefits
of both systems
um and so i've been doing javascript for
a really long time as
i've said already but this is you can we
can actually do this
in in on javascript clients right so
this is all asynchronous code written in
a straight line way
i can run three parallel requests
asking whoever whichever request for a
web result
or an image or video returns the fastest
and not only can i do that
i can kill all the requests if they
don't satisfy um
that we don't return the results in 80
milliseconds
no callbacks no manual csp like sorry
cps no manual cps
getting my csp cps backwards um
so this is amazing like that i can you
can do this right in this system
and and this is the type of thing that
of course she sharp programmers are able
to do because they have
async await scala now has something very
similar to async await
um and this i think makes asynchronous
programming bearable i i really think
that
most languages it's absolutely terrible
to do
um so why why why would a javascript
developer be interested in all these
things
right what what good is it to explore
these crazy concepts
um so it's it's it's important to me
because
uh i can actually run because of
clojurescript i work on clojurescript i
work in the compiler
i can run all these things in javascript
so here i'm running um
a recent build of of the v8 javascript
engine and so
in 1993 peter norvig when he wrote the
paradigms of artificial intelligence
programming he
solved the zebra puzzle which is a
classic constraint satisfaction puzzle
and he did in 17 seconds this was after
he built up a prologue compiler and all
this stuff and did all this work
in like 17 seconds and that seemed
amazing because um a naive
solution to this problem the zebra
puzzle
you have to look at 24 billion possible
solutions right
but prologue back tracking and
unification you can do this in
17 seconds in 1993. so how fast can i do
this in javascript so i have a version
of core logic that targets closure
script
and running against uh v8
so you can see once v8 gets warmed up i
can do it in 16 milliseconds
right
oh and let me just
that's pretty cool and the other thing
is that is that i think for functional
programming to be taken
seriously i think we have to take
interactive interactive applications
seriously
functional programming is an extremely
good story on the server side for
control managing complexity
but it's important that like what if i
want to make an interactive game
and it absolutely is imperative that i
can do 350
and 350 000 iterations and i know i have
to do it in 16 milliseconds
that's all the time i have to do my work
and so i spent some time taking
a notch who does minecraft and i said
can clojurescript
run his code a version of his code in a
mostly purely functional manner
and deliver the exact same frame rate
this is not webgl so this is we're
actually doing all the rasterization
on on a canvas right so this means we
have to be able to loop around
and draw pixels and we only have 16
milliseconds to do it
right and this is closure script
[Applause]
one last little demo it's just kind of
fun
oh yeah okay so so pattern matching so
i'm going to show
how fast we can pattern match on a
persistent vector versus how fast we can
match on a javascript array using the
same special
specialization technique i talked about
so for one million iterations we can we
can
we can test for balance in about one
second uh if we use if we use the array
specialization
we can do it 10 million times in less
than two seconds
right that's pretty cool so paper to
javascript i think that's pretty awesome
um so yeah so that's really all i had to
talk about and so
hopefully i've inspired you that papers
are really cool
they're really important to to um uh to
read and to
to think about and to try to put into
practice because they can make
our lives as programmers both more fun
and more productive so i sort of tweaked
allen k's classic phrase
you know in order to predict the future
you have to invent it i say the best way
to predict the future is to read papers
and engineering thank you